Mein Name ist Yusuf Seyskin. Ich bin heute der zuständige Ast für Sie und werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Was Sie Fragen haben, suggen Sie bitte nicht, mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Bender Walter.
Könnten Sie bitte den Nach- und Vornamen langsam buchstabieren?
B-E-N-E-R.
Bender?
Nachnamen?
W-A-L-T-E-R.
Walter.
Sind Sie Herr oder Frau Walter?
Herr.
Wie alt sind Sie Herr Walter?
37.
Wie lange sind Sie gebusst?
Meine Gebusstatum ist 2. Juni 1988.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,70 Meter.
Ihr Gewicht bitte?
75 Kilogramm schwer.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Herr Walter?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Lehrer?
Entschuldigung, Lehrer, ja.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Ja, mein Hausarzt heißt Hirshimid.
Jetzt kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Was fühlt Sie heute zu uns, Herr Walter?
Ich habe Handgelenkschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit morgen, Doktor.
Seit morgen möchte ich sehr starke Gelenkschmerzen.
Haben Sie einen Unfall?
Ja, ja, ja.
Könnten Sie mir bitte beschreiben, was ist passiert?
Heute Morgen habe ich in der Badewanne aufgeruscht
und auf meine linken Hände gefallen, Doktor.
Linke Handgelenk?
Ja, ja, linke Handgelenk.
Haben Sie Schwellungen, offene Wunde oder Rötung bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe Rötung und Schwellungen bemerkt,
aber es gibt keine offene Wunde.
Haben Sie Kopfverletzungen?
Nein, ich habe keine Kopfverletzung.
Haben Sie noch andere Schmerzen in irgendwelchen Körperregionen, Herr Walter?
Ich fühle mich nicht an den anderen Körperteilen Schmerzen,
Doktor.
Könnten Sie mir bitte diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Du Schmerzen oder?
Ja, Schmerzen, Doktor.
Allen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind in meinen Händen und in meinen Händen und oben.
Können Sie Ihre Hände gut bewegen oder haben Sie Bewegungsanschränkungen, Herr Walter?
Nein, Doktor.
Ich habe eine Bewegungsschränkung, ja.
Bewegungsanschränkungen, ja.
Echt?
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente genommen?
Ja, ich nehme, ich habe 15 mg Ibuprofen angenommen,
aber es würde mir nicht geholfen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala, wobei es am stärksten ist?
Es ist ungefähr 7 bis 8.
Könnten Sie bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten oder ich kann Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben, Herr Walter?
Ja, Doktor. Ich kann warten, ja.
Gut. Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, Herr Walter?
Ja.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Ich habe keine Schwindelig, nein Doktor.
Ihnen schwarz vor Augen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Herzrhythmusstörungen oder Herzstolpen bemerkt?
Nein.
Haben Sie Atemnot, Husten?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ich habe keine Übel.
Müssen Sie sich übergeben vor oder nach dem Unfall?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Walter?
Normalerweise gut, aber seit Morgen habe ich kaum Appetit. Vielleicht wegen Schmerzen.
Gut. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab- oder zu genommen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor. Ich bin immer gleich. Mein Gewicht ist immer gleich, ja.
Gut.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen oder beim Stuhlgang?
Nein. Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich fühle mich nicht fieberig. Ich habe nicht gemessen.
Haben Sie Kühnung in betroffenen Bereichen gemacht?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen, Herr Walter?
Nein, Doktor. Ich schlafe gut.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Bei mir sind keine irgendwelche Krankheiten bekannt.
Gut. Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig?
Medikamente? Ja, ja. Zum Beispiel eine Paracetamol Tablette.
Ich habe manchmal Rücken Schmerzen.
Rücken Schmerzen.
Wie oft nehmen Sie?
Paracetamol Tablette.
Ja, ja. Wie oft?
300 mg. Bei mir.
Bei mir.
Haben Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe es vorhin schon gemacht.
Ich habe eine Diktarm-Operation gemacht.
Diktarm oder Bilindarm?
Bilindarm, ich weiß nicht.
Bilindarm und Fernhoch? Ja, ja.
In welchem Alter erinnert Sie sich?
Ja, recht.
In welchem Alter?
Recht, recht.
Ja, ungefähr. Ich bin 17 Jahre alt.
War das Operation komplikationlos?
Ja, ja. Das war komplikationlos.
Gut zu hören.
Haben Sie Allergien, Herr Walter?
Allergien?
Oder Unverträglichkeiten gegen Lebensmittel?
Ich habe keine Allergen oder Unverträglichkeiten, Doktor.
Gut. Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche 30 Zigaretten pro Tag seit 20 Jahren.
30 Zigaretten?
Seit 20 Jahren.
Das ist zu viel für Ihre Gesundheit.
Ich habe viele Mal auf den Zigaretten aufgehören.
Aber ich habe nicht verstanden.
Wir haben eine Abteilung. Wir können einen Termin vereinbaren für Sie.
Sie können eine Begattung nehmen.
Ich wäre Ihnen dankbar, wenn Sie mir helfen, Doktor.
Natürlich. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke eine Flasche oder einen Liter Bier pro Tag.
Täglich?
Ja, täglich.
Einen Liter oder eine Flasche?
Einen Liter.
Das ist auch zu viel, Herr Walter.
Ja, leider.
Nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich.
Aus medizinischen Gründen fragen wir immer.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Ich habe keine Drogen probiert.
Gut, ich freu mich.
Danke schön.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau zusammen?
Ja, ich lebe mit meiner Frau.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bei Ihrer Familie?
Mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck.
Und meine Mutter hat Zuckerkrankheit.
Welche Typ? Wissen Sie das? Typ 2 oder?
Typ 2, ja.
Haben Sie beide noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, das war es, Doktor.
Das war es.
Das ist keine andere Krankheit.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Herr Walter?
Ich meine gegen Kinderkrankheit, Covid-19?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, so wie drei Mal gegen Covid-19.
Waren Sie in Lester seitdem im Ausland?
Vor sechs Monaten war ich in Griechenland, für Urlaub, Doktor.
Für?
Für Urlaub.
Verstehe.
Trägen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich treibe manchmal Tennis.
Oder Wandern.
Anwohnende.
Noch andere Fragen für Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Haben Sie Kliniken?
Nein, ich habe keine Kliniken.
Ist Ihnen Taubheitsgefühl oder Kribben aufgefallen?
Nein, ich habe keine Kribben.
Ich habe es mir notiert, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das richtig war.
Sie nehmen dagegen Paracetamol Tablet, oder?
Ja, ich habe einmalig 500 mg Ibuprofen Tablet.
Ibuprofen.
Heute Morgen habe ich es mir angekündigt.
Alles klar, Herr Walter.
Ich habe viele wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Was habe ich, Doktor?
Sie haben auf der linken Seite gefallen.
Sie haben Rötungen und Schwellungen und Schmerzen.
Es könnte Handgelenkknochenbruch sein, Herr Walter.
Aber es ist zufügig etwas Genaues zu sagen.
Jetzt werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Danach werden wir eine operative Diagnostik veranlassen.
Dann können wir entscheiden.
Was ist operativ?
Operative Diagnostik ist ein bildgebendes Verfahren.
Röntgenaufnahme oder CT, Computertomographie.
Ich verstehe.
Wurde ich operiert?
Wie gesagt, es ist zufügig etwas Genaues zu sagen.
Wenn wir die Ergebnisse bekommen, können wir mehr übersprechen.
Danke schön. Ich warte auf Sie.
Sie bleiben hier. Dann komme ich wieder.
Okay, danke.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen die Patienten vorstellen, die ich in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Ich bin Walter, ein 37-jähriger Patient.
Er wurde am 2.6.1988 geboren.
Er ist 1,70 Meter groß und 75 Kilogramm schwer.
Er hatte sich seit heute Morgen bestehende Handgelenke geschmissen.
Links mit Ausstrahlung in den Oberarm oder in die Humerus.
Das war ein Unfall.
Er war im Badezimmer.
Er ist ausgeruscht.
Er ist auf dem linken Handgelenk gefallen.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegen Rötung, Oedema und Bewegungseinschränkung vor.
Er hat dagegen Ibuprofen genommen.
Aber es hat ihm nicht geholfen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 7 bis 8 von 10 bewertet.
Die Frage nach Pharestese, Atemnot oder Dyspnoe, Herzrhythmusstörungen wurde verleumd.
Er hatte keine Kopfverletzung.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Inapetens.
Seit heute Morgen wegen der Schmerzen.
Bei ihm keine chronischen Vorerkrankungen bekannt.
Er nimmt gelegentlich 500 mg Paracetamol ein.
Er nimmt bei Bedarf 500 mg Paracetamol ein.
Wegen der Schmerzen.
Bei ihm wurde mit 17 Jahren eine Apendektomie durchgeführt.
Bei ihm keine Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er rauche seit 20 Jahren 30 Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinke täglich 1 Liter Bier.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Er lebt mit seiner Ehefrau zusammen.
In der Familienanamnese fand er arterielle Hypertonik.
Bei Vater.
Diabetes mellitus type 2 bei der Mutter.
Er ist Einzelkind.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Er spielt regelmäßig Tennis.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose lautet auf Handgelenkfraktur.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik kommt von Bandriss,
Prällungen, Muskelspannung,
Weichteil, Gewebe, Verletzung in Betracht.
Zur Diagnostik würde ich bei dem Patienten
eine entsprechende körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Zuerst würde ich die vitalen Parameter erfassen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und oskultieren.
Bei der Inspektion achte ich oder beurteile ich
meinen Zustand des Patienten.
In diesem Fall ist eine neurologische Untersuchung wegweisend.
Dabei würde ich Motorik, Sensibilität, Reflex und Gelenkeinschränkung überprüfen.
Bei der weiteren Diagnostik würde ich eine bildgebende Methode veranlassen.
Zunächst würde ich zwei Ebenen Handgelenkröntgen veranlassen.
In diesem Fall würde ich die Computer-Tomographie im Handgelenk veranlassen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtstiagnose bestätigen,
würde ich zunächst den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Dann würde ich eine Venöse-Zugang legen, um eine Venöse-Therapie zu ermöglichen.
Danach würde ich die Analgetik und Verabreichung verabreichen.
Dann würde ich eine Chirurgische Konzilveranlassung machen.
Dann würde ich eine Vertikodanlage machen.
Hat der Patient eine kalte Haut bemerkt?
Ich habe es nicht gefragt, Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe nur die Rötung, Schwellung und offene Wunde gefragt.
Er hat Rötung und Oedema, aber keine offene Wunde.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich überprüfen.
Wie können Sie überprüfen?
Wir können überprüfen, aber nicht durch.
Bei der Palpation kann ich überprüfen.
Okay.
Sie abtasten die peripherliche Pulse, oder?
Bei der Palpation sollte ich die Durchfluchtung überprüfen.
Peripherische Pulse.
Wir sollten peripherische Pulse kontrollen oder überprüfen.
Warum veranlasst Sie eine CT?
Bei der CT können wir darstellen, nicht nur Knochen, sondern auch eine Bandesstruktur.
Bei der CT.
Oder denken Sie weiter überprüfen?
Wenn es eine unklarere Faktur gibt, können wir die CT genauer darstellen.
Okay.
Ich habe keine weitere Frage.
Hier eine Frage.
Was sind die sicher und unsichersten Faktorzeichen?
Ich kenne es als pathologische Mobilisierung.
Ja, Herr Oberarzt, vielen Dank.
Pathologische Bewegung und Prellung.
Grosse Ödämme.
Pathologische Bewegung ist entscheidend.
Welche unsichere Faktorzeichen hat dieser Patient?
Er hat Wirtung und Ödämme. Das ist ein unsicherer Faktorzeichen.
Ich habe die anderen Fragen nicht gestellt.
Aber er hat Bewegungseinschränkungen.
Ja, das ist auch ein unsicherer Faktorzeichen.
Und hat er ein sicheres Faktorzeichen?
Ich habe es nicht gefragt.
Bei der persönlichen Untersuchung werde ich überprüfen.
Okay, und noch einmal bitte, welche sicheren Faktorzeichen kennen Sie?
Pathologische Bewegung.
Ja, noch etwas?
Prellung oder?
Also Krepitation.
Deformität.
Wie können wir Deformität überprüfen?
Sie können die pathologische Bewilligkeit überprüfen.
Wenn der Patient eine Deformität hat, kann er eine pathologische Bewilligung haben.
Und offene Faktor können Sie feststellen.
Das ist auch ein sicheres Faktorzeichen.
Okay.
Wirtung, Fachbegriff, Kalor oder?
Kalor ist Überwärmung.
Palor ist nicht Wirtung.
Also das ist Palor.
Was ist das denn?
Während eines Anime können wir Palor feststellen.
Ja.
Blatze.
Genau.
Okay, das ist genug, ich glaube.
Wir haben noch 20 Sekunden.
Ja.
Wie war es?
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Und ich würde ihn Ihnen vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, habe ich bitte.
Ich berichte über den 37-jährigen Patienten, Herr Walter, der 1,70 Meter groß ist und 75 Kilogramm wiegt.
Der Patient kommt heute zu uns mit seit heute Morgen 5-ten,
mit Ausstrahlung in den linken Oberschenkel und Fuss.
Außerdem klagt der Patient über Ruhbo,
die Handgelände sind voll und schwellig.
Die Frage nach Kopfverletzung wurde vermeint.
Woher strahlen die Schmerzen aus?
In den Oberschenkel und Fuss.
Nein, Oberarm und Hand.
Es tut mir leid, Herr Oberhart.
Ich habe falsch bemerkt wegen Stress.
Alles gut.
Machen Sie mit.
Die Frage nach Kopfverletzung wurde vermeint.
Cerebrale Trauma wurde vermeint.
Ibuprofen Einnahme hat keine Linderung gebracht.
Die Beschwerden sind auftreten, nachdem er in der Badetzima gefallen ist.
Die Frage nach Tachikardie, Dyspne, Fibaschütelfrost, Nausea und Emesis wurde vermeint.
Der Patient bewertete seine Schmerzen 7-8 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Die Patienten sind nicht vor der Krankheit bekannt.
Sie haben eine Parasite und schmerzen sehr schwer.
Mit 17 Jahren wurde bei den Patienten Tonsillektomie erfolgt.
Die Frage nach Allergie und Unverträglichkeiten wurde vermeint.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Er treibt regelmäßig Tennisspiel.
Er raucht 30 Zigaretten pro Tag und trinkt ein Flasche Bier täglich.
Drogenkonsum wurde vermeint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, väterlicherseits Arterialhypertonie und Mutterlicherseits Diabetes mellitus Typ 2.
Er ist Lehrer und verheiratet.
Er hat keine Kinder und erlebt mit seiner Frau.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf Distal Radius Fracture hin.
Differenziell diagnostisch kommen Weichgewebe und Sehnenverletzungen.
Welche Symptome sprechen für eine Distal Radius Fracture?
Der Patient hat sehr starke Schmerzen zuerst.
Er hat auch Schwellung, Rötung oder Dolor, Rupor.
Er hat eine Trauma-Geschichte.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Distal Radius Fracture.
Eine eingeschränkte Bewegung ist auch ein starkes Signal für Distal Radius Fracture.
Okay, machen Sie weiter.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Bei der Palpation achte ich darauf, ob es Druckdollens gibt.
Bei der Inspektion achte ich darauf, ob es eine Deformität gibt.
Außerdem werde ich eine zweiebene Röntgenaufnahme durchführen.
Ich werde die Fracture beschleunigen.
Wenn ich die Handgelände verändern werde, werde ich die Operation planen.
Eine orthopädische Konzil wird sinnvoll, die Behandlung zu optimieren und eine mögliche Operation zu bestimmen.
Ich werde den Patienten stationär aufnehmen und eine Zugangspartikel verbreiten.
Diese Schmerzen sind sehr starke Schmerzen und um eine mögliche Operation zu vorbereiten.
Welche Labouruntersuchungen würden Sie kontrollieren?
Ich werde die Grußblutbildentzündungsparameter, Nieren- und Leberwerte, Koagulationparameter, Hepatitmarker und Anti-Hib, Anti-HBS, HBSG bestimmen.
Ich werde die Operation bestimmen und eine mögliche Operation zu vorbereiten.
Brauchen wir eine Blutgruppe kontrollieren?
Die Blutgruppe bestimmen ist auch nötig, um die Blutgruppe zu vermeiden.
Welche sichere und unsichere Fracture-Zeichen kennen Sie?
Unsichere Zeichen sind Hämatom, Rötung, Ruprum und Schmerzen.
Unsichere Zeichen sind Deformität und Krepitation.
Ich werde eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen, ob es eine Taubeizugefühl oder Nervenverletzungen gibt.
Ich werde auch die Finger und die Hände abtasten, um mögliche Durchblutstörungen auszuschließen.
Eine Komplikation von Distal Radius Fracture ist Kompartment-Syndrom.
Das bedeutet Durchblutstörung und sehr starke Schmerzen.
Die Patiente muss engmaschig kontrolliert werden.
Welche anderen Komplikationen kennen Sie bei einer Faktur?
Besonders in offener Faktur kann keine Infektion aufsteigen.
Die Nervenverletzungen, die Arterie und die Venenverletzungen, kann auftreten.
Und der Kompartment-Syndrom kann auftreten.
Fettembolie, das können wir sagen.
Nach dem Kompartment-Syndrom kann die ischämische Kontraktur auftreten.
Aber Fettembolie ist sehr wenig, besonders in kleinen Knochen.
In großen Femur- oder Pelvic-Frakturen ist Fettembolie nicht selten.
Welche Knochenbruchtypen kennen Sie?
In Handgelenk gibt es Extension- oder Flexion-Frakturen.
Extension-Fraktur heißt Collet-Fraktur.
Flexion-Fraktur heißt Simit-Fraktur.
Normalerweise gibt es Displaced-Frakturen.
Auf Latein können wir sagen, dass es Faktbegriffen gibt.
Displaced-Frakturen oder Deplacé-Frakturen oder undisplaced-Frakturen kann auftreten.
Wenn die Faktur nicht displaced ist, können wir sie mit Gips oder Konservativ behandeln.
Aber mit Displaced-Frakturen müssen wir auf jeden Fall operieren.
Welche operative Verfahren kennen Sie?
In der operativen Verfahren gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
Offene oder nicht offene Operation.
Mit Platte und Schraub-Osteosynthese können wir offene Operation durchführen.
Nicht offene Operation ist geschlossene Reposition mit Kirschen.
Mit K-Weihrauch.
Das weiß ich nicht in Deutsch.
Oder mit Gips können wir operieren.
Das ist gut.
Das ist genau die Frage.
Der Ziel ist, die Fakten zu kümmern.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Wir haben heute einen neuen Patienten.
Ich möchte Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Ich bin der Herr Bende Walter.
Er ist 37 Jahre alt.
Er ist 75 Kilogramm schwer.
Er ist 1,70 Meter groß.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen des bestehenden, steckenden, progradienten, linke Seite.
Der Patient erklärt, dass er heute Morgen in der Badewanne ausgeruscht und auf eine Hand gefallen hat.
und auf eine Hand gefallen.
Danach sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Des Weiteren gibt er an, dass die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten
und im Verlauf der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden sind.
Die Schmerzintensität würde mit 7 bis 8, 10 auf eine Schmerzskala bewerben.
Die einmalige Einnahme von 500 mg Ibuprofen hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Er klagt über Ödama und Rötung im betroffenen Bereich.
Außerdem bereitet er schmerzbedingte, eingeschränkte Bewegung.
Die Frage nach Parasitezi, Hypostese, offene Wunde und Vertigo würde verneint.
Die Vegetative-Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf schmerzbedingte Inapetens.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Handgelenkfraktur aus.
Da die Patient dafür typische Symptome aufweist,
dass die Patient leider unter Schwellung, Schmerzen, Rötung und es gibt eine Unfallgeschichte.
Das spricht für Handgelenkschmerzen.
Als differential Diagnose kommen Prellung oder Weisgewebe Fährleitzung im Betracht.
Welche Weisgewebe Fährleitzungen?
Dichtorsion, Luxation, Distorsion.
Sie haben recht Herr Oberhaus.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten zuerst die Vitaparameter überwachen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten körperliche Untersuchungen, beide körperliche Untersuchungen auf die Darabauf, Farbeveränderungen,
Offene, Wunde, Kolorube im Betroffene Bereich vorlegen.
Außerdem würde ich den Patienten Handarteriale Pulse abtasten.
Für diese Patienten ist es sinnvoll eine neurologische Untersuchung durchzuführen.
Dabei würde ich Probleme, oder nicht Probleme, aber Schwerungen,
Motorrad und andere Funktionen vorlegen.
Außerdem würde ich den Patienten palpieren, beide Arte darauf auf Kreptation oder andere Deformationen.
Das würde ich vorhanden sein.
Neben körperlichen Untersuchungen wäre ich ein Laberunterzuchungen sinnvoll, um ungefährliche Diagnose zu bestätigen.
Dabei würde ich die große Blutgruppe, die Entzündungsparameter, die Gerinnungsparameter, die Lebewerter, die Nierenwerter bestimmen lassen.
Dann würde ich die Röntgen auf dem Handgelenk in zwei Ebenen durchführen, um mögliche Fraktur zu bestimmen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten eine MRT durchführen, um seine Verlassung oder Wahrheit zu verhindern.
Dann würde ich die Röntgen auf dem Handgelenk in zwei Ebenen durchführen, um seine Verlassung oder Wahrheit zu verhindern.
Herr Kölegen, was würden Sie mit der Operation bei den Patienten durchführen?
Ich würde die Operation durchführen, aber der Patient hat keine Offene.
Was machen Sie mit der Operation?
Ich würde eine Gipstherapie behandeln.
Ich würde den Patienten über vier bis sechs Wochen ruhig stellen.
Ich bin nicht sicher, aber ich denke, dass ich nach einer halben Monate den Patienten kontrollieren werde.
Ich habe eine Nachdenkoperation gemacht.
Wir müssen den Patienten kontrollieren, um mögliche Blutungen oder andere Probleme zu kontrollieren.
Was ist die hoffnungsvolle Ursache für eine Distalleradiospraktur?
Die Stürze, zum Beispiel.
Bei allen Patienten hat eine besondere Krankheit.
Was ist die hoffnungsvolle Ursache für eine Distalleradiospraktur?
Die Stürze, zum Beispiel.
Das ist die hoffnungsvolle Ursache für eine Distalleradiospraktur.
Welche klinischen Symptome sind die hoffnungsvolle Ursache für eine Distalleradiospraktur?
Die hoffnungsvolle Ursache für eine Distalleradiospraktur ist die hoffnungsvolle Ursache für eine Distalleradiospraktur.
Was kontrollieren Sie während der Körperlichunterzüge besonders?
Es ist sehr wichtig, Lungen zu kontrollieren und mögliche Embolle auszuschließen.
Dann kontrolliere ich Kopf, Brust und Bauch, mögliche Verlatsungen, Farbeveränderungen oder Rötungen.
Was empfehlen Sie bei den Patienten, die eine operative Therapie empfehlen?
Wenn ein Patient eine instabilen Frakturen hat, müssen wir den Patienten eine Operation durchführen.
Wenn ein Patient eine Artillerienfrakturen hat, muss der Patienten eine Artillerienfrakturen durchführen.
Welche Komplikationen können nach der Operation aufstehen?
Nach der Operation kann es Blut, Infektionen, Kompartmentsyndrom, Nervenverletzung, Arterieverletzung oder Venomverletzung möglich sein.
Ich denke, eine sehr wichtige Komplikation ist eine falsche Heilung.
Bewegungseinschränkung, Arthrose, Pseudarathrose.
Ich habe keine Erfahrung über diese Themen. Ich bin Dermatologe.
Was empfehlen Sie bei den Patienten nach der Operation oder nach dem Gips?
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig. Eine krankes Gymnastik.
Empfehlen Sie den Patienten eine krankes Gymnastik zu machen.
Hochlagerung, Füllung, Schmerztherapie, germäßige Peripherie, Puls kontrollieren, nach Immobilisation Physiotherapie.
Und wann empfehlen Sie bei den Patienten nach Kontrolle?
Nach der Operation oder?
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich denke vielleicht nach einer Woche.
Ich weiß es aber nach einer Woche vielleicht.